the graph and Ryan Feld facility has
been producing energy since the early
1980s but it's operator eon has decided
to take Germany's oldest reactor offline
in May Chancellor Merkel's government is
putting increasing reliance on renewable
energy and is advocating a gradual
phase-out of nuclear power knocked him
after the Fukushima accident we knew it
was just a matter of time until graphene
fed would be taken off the grid we have
to live with it that's the way things go
it's a government decision when it
esteemed the plant is provided an
economic boost for Northern Bavaria for
decades and it shows abundant tax
revenues allowed the village of graphene
Reinfeldt to restore its historic
central square and build a modern
library the nuclear facility was a major
source of employment as well but the
boom times are over the mayor is already
doing some budget cutting the plan
shutdown will mean a drastic drop in tax
revenue for now at least there are no
worries about unemployment 300 workers
at the plant will stay on to manage the
shutdown the locals have mixed feelings
about this end of an era Moqaddas knee
tucks to the reactor never bothered me
we have to generate power somehow made
inch dome finger school I think it's
been operating long enough I'm lit as s
odd Milan they should have alternatives
in place before they switch off
everything this gets woeful little close
down but they'll still store the tanks
with nuclear waste here I can get off it
the spent nuclear fuel rods will have to
be cooled for years before they are
locked away in special caster tanks and
stored here there's more than enough
space in the plants operating licence
runs through 2046 environmental
activists say the hall is unsafe and
there's another thing worrying them the
first up is dear we're afraid that the
temporary storage could turn into a
permanent
obviously the way it's constructed makes
it unsuitable for this they would have
to improve the structure that'll
increase the costs and the risks will
remain and escape on foot INSEAD black
for hunt even when the reactors cooling
towers are gone the radioactive waste
will remain a graph and Reinfeldt
possibly for decades to come